you see that video of the little girl
that's sitting on a dock and a seal
jumps up and grabs her in the ass and
pulls her into the water
gerrae see that Jamie yeah and I didn't
think that seals ever did something like
that before I don't know
I did see a special once about how
dolphins could be kind of aggressive
with each other like they could harm you
know I could leave this so seal is
sitting there and this girl hmm see line
actually look at this it comes up and
they think that see what so cute yeah
yeah but it I think it was probably
looking for a handout and these people
weren't giving it to her I mean she
turns her buddy yeah [ __ ] I'd be right
back
fill that [ __ ] puddle with lead oh
yeah yeah they jumped up fast yeah
they're predators I mean the things you
know they're not eating plants in the
water they're eating fish and [ __ ] yeah
whatever they can get ahold oh they're
probably birds and stuff too they're
probably used to scooping things up but
I bet that what that's from is them
getting too acclimated to people if
you're feeding them oh yeah there's a
they have an issue in Boulder where
Boulder is your bin Colorado yeah yeah
beautiful all right gorgeous super
liberal like as progressive as it gets
right you're moving in San Francisco oh
yeah I think Boulder is right up there
but there's less people in there you
know everyone's real healthy and active
and hiking and stuff like that they
don't allow hunting for mountain goats
on the weekends because there's so many
people hiking and going that they don't
want people killing these mountain goats
in front of them because people freak
out even though they have decided that
they have to control the population and
kill a certain number of them but so
many people go out there that these
things aren't scared of people so it's
created this really weird situation
where if you are hunting them you're
you're almost hunting something that's
domesticated people feed them Cheetos so
much so that a friend of mine was
talking about it that he was up there
with his daughter his daughter opened up
a bag of Cheetos and the goat walked
right to a wild goat lives out in the
[ __ ] woods walked right up to his
daughter and they were laugh and she
opened up the bag of Cheetos and put it
and he stuffed his head in the bag of
Cheetos he knew what to do and he's he's
in this guy who was talking about this
is a hunter and he's like this [ __ ]
goat has like cheeto dust all over its
face like it's the craziest thing its
face is all red with cheeto dust and
it's sitting there chewing these cheese
like it's done it before
yeah and it's just that that goat had
diabetes I think probably eventually
right yeah I was in Costa Rica there's
another similar situation and we were
staying at this Four Seasons out there
and the monkeys have got very customed
to people being there and so they come
by and they hang out and they're like
trying to get things from you and my
daughter opened up a package Oreos and
the monkey just jumped onto this little
ledge like a couple feet away from her
and and my wife was like I really don't
think it's a good idea that we feed this
thing Oreos and I said wow you know it's
probably gonna get eaten by a [ __ ]
crocodile anyway I mean it's gonna
poisoning it is that what you're
thinking and it's not gonna eat this
every day it's not gonna be a normal
part of its diet but we hand the monkey
and Oreo it pops open the Oreo and
starts chewing on the frosting like a
little kid and then we're like oh this
little [ __ ] probably gets these things
every week right so begs the question
does he know how to do that because he's
watched some human do it or are we
innately wired to do that with Oreos woo
I think he knows how to do it because
someone's giving him Oreos so many times
then he knows that's the good stuff the
good stuff the middle they should just
sell that I think there's only good
because you can you can contrast it with
it comes back to the contrast exactly I
think you're right I think you're really
right I think it was just pure middle
it'd be pretty gross yeah if they
probably sold pure middle
he would buy it but if they sold those
black cookies by themselves no and buy
those back but gross things either
biscuits worse cookies like those could
once you eat the white stuff you like
alright I'll eat this stupid ass black
cookie it's the sunk cost it's like a
cold cookie here it is there's a little
monkey doing it look they grabbed her
from you and then just [ __ ] love or
it looks look at him opening up
immediately open it up and start chewing
that white stuff yeah crazy
we had there's a thing that is called
the quwata Mundi have you ever heard of
those it's uh it's related to the
raccoon it's this weird animal that
lives mostly in Central and South
America and it has a northern range that
extends into Arizona all the way up into
Mesa I think like it gets into the areas
where it gets cold but Arizona I think
is the only state in the u.s. that has
it but it's this weird-looking monkey
raccoon thing that is so domesticated
that we gave it some grapes here it is
we gave it some grapes and this little
[ __ ] there it is I mean look at that
weird little thing it came and sat we
had like a little patio area in the
hotel room and it came and sat down with
us it's so calm that it's sat and went
underneath one of the chairs and took a
nap after we gave it some grapes like
what we're hanging around my daughters
are running around making noise and this
thing's just chilling it's like a pet it
was a total pet it was a total pet yeah
there they are
they're cool man weird-looking things
people eat them apparently apparently
they hunt them in Arizona
yeah
I mean after seeing this it's just like
I don't think I can hunt that I'd have
to be pretty hungry to eat one of those
they're so cute a little face weird
little animal men really interesting
yeah our relationship with animals is
very odd when they get into close
proximity yeah yeah we've got a wicked
coyote problem and
in Diego and at least in the part I live
in and you know just one of those things
once we got rid of mountain lions
because no one who wants mountain lions
around the Coyotes run amok is that what
it is I think I mean that's time a
friend of mine about this the other day
actually and he was saying that there's
probably only like in our neighborhood
there's probably only like two mountain
lions left and the the Coyotes just
they've exploded there there's so many
of them around like and it doesn't
really bother me that much I mean I
actually kind of like listening to them
howl but you know if you if they get
into your chicken coop